we've seen the Moore's law in
communication we've seen the Moore's
law-like type of growth in uh
computation
and you're anticipating we're going to
see that in digital fabrication can you
actually first of all describe what you
mean by this term digital fabrication so
the Casual meaning is the computer
controls the tool to make something and
that was invented when MIT stole it in
1952. yeah um there's the deep meaning
of what the ribosome does of a
computation of a dis a digital
description doesn't describe a thing a
digital description becomes the thing
that's where the that's that's the path
to the Star Trek replicator
and that's the thing that doesn't exist
yet
now I think the the best way to
understand what this roadmap looks like
is to now bring in Fab labs and how they
relate to all of this what are Fab Labs
so here here's a sequence
um with colleagues I accidentally
started a network of what's now 2500
digital fabrication Community Labs
called Fab Labs right now in 125
countries and they double every year and
a half that's called lassa's law after
Sherry Lasseter who I'll explain so
here's the sequence
uh we started Center for bits and atoms
to do the kind of research we're talking
about we had all of these machines and
then had a problem it would take a
lifetime of classes to learn to use all
the machines
so with
you know colleagues who helped start CBA
we began a class modestly called how to
make almost anything yeah and there's no
big agenda it was just it was aimed at a
few research students to use the
machines and it were completely
unprepared for the first time we taught
it we were swamped by every year since
hundreds of students try to take the
class it's one of the most
oversubscribed classes at MIT
um students would say things like can
you teach this at MIT it seems too
useful it's just how to work these
machines and the students in the class I
would teach them all the skills to use
all these tools and then they would do
projects integrating them and they were
amazing so Kelly was a sculptor no
engineering background uh her project
was she made a device that saves up
screams when you're mad and placed them
back later
and saves up screams when you're mad and
plays them back later you scream into
this device and it it it deadens The
Sound records it and then when it's
convenient releases your screen okay can
we just just like pause on the
Brilliance of that invention creation
the art
I don't know the Brilliance who is this
equation Kelly Dobson going on to do a
number of interesting things uh mijin
who's gone on to do a number of
interesting things uh made a dress
instrumented with sensors and spines and
when somebody creepy comes close it
would defend your personal space it also
varies
um another project early on was a web
browser for parrots which have the
cognitive ability of a young child and
lets parrots surf the Internet
you know another another was an arm
clock an alarm clock you wrestle with
and prove you're awake and what connects
all of these is
so MIT made the first real-time computer
the Whirlwind that was transistorized as
the TX the TX was spun off from MIT as
the PDP pdp's
where the mini computers that created
the internet
so outside MIT was deck Prime Wang data
General the whole mini computer industry
the whole Computing industry was there
and it all failed when Computing became
personal
Ken Olsen the head of digital famously
said you don't need a computer at home
there's a little background to that but
but deck you know completely missed
Computing became personal so I mentioned
all of that because
I was asking how to do digital
fabrication but not really why the
students in this how to make class were
showing me that the killer app of
digital fabrication is personal
fabrication yeah how do you jump to the
personal fabrication so Kelly didn't
make the screen body because it was for
a thesis she wasn't writing a research
paper it wasn't a business model she
wanted it was because she wanted one
yeah it was personal expression going
back to me and vocational schools
personal expression in these new means
of expression
so that's happened every year since it
literally is called the course is
literally called how to make almost
anything yep a legendary course at MIT
yep yep every year and it's grown to
multiple Labs
um at MIT with as many people involved
in teaching us taking it and there's
even a Harvard lab for the MIT class
what what have you learned about humans
colliding with the Fab Lab about what
the capacity of humans to be creative
and to build I I mentioned Marvin
another Mentor at MIT sadly no longer
living is Seymour pepper so pepper
studied with Piaget he came to MIT to
get access to the early compute Piaget
was a Pioneer in how kids learn
um papert came to MIT to get access to
the early computers with the goal of
letting kids play with them uh Piaget
helped show kids are like scientists
they they learn as scientists and it
gets kind of throttled out of them
Seymour wanted to let her kids have a
broader landscape to play Seymour's work
LED with Mitch Resnick to Lego logo
Mindstorms all of that stuff as Fab Labs
spread and we started creating
educational programs for kids in them
Seymour said something really
interesting he made a gesture he said it
was a thorn in his side
that they invented What's called the
turtle a robot kids could early robot
kids could program to connect it to a
Mainframe computer Seymour said
the goal was not for the kids to program
the robot it was for the kids to create
the robot
and so in that sense the Fab Labs which
for me were just this accident he
described as sort of this fulfillment of
the Arc of kids learn by experimenting
it was to give them the tools to create
not just assemble things and program
things but actually create so coming to
your question
what I've learned
is
MIT a few years back somebody added
added up businesses from it spun off
from MIT and it's the world's 10th
economy it falls between India and
Russia and I view that in a way as a bad
number because it's only a few thousand
people and these aren't uniquely the
four thousand brightest people it's just
a productive environment for them and
what we found is in rural Indian
villages in African Shanty towns and
Arctic
um Hamlet I find exactly precisely that
profile so
um lingside it a few hours above Trump
so way above the Arctic circles it's so
far north of satellite dishes look at
the ground not the sky
um Hans Christian in the lab was
considered a problem in the local school
because they couldn't teach him anything
I showed him a few projects next time I
came back he was designing and building
Little Robot vehicles and in
um South Africa in I mentioned social
Govi in this apartheid Township the
local Technical Institute taught kids
how to make bricks and fold sheets it
was punitive but to piso in the Fab Lab
was actually doing all the work of my
MIT classes and so over and over we
found precisely the same kind of bright
invent of
um creativity
uh and historically the answer was
go you're smart go away it's sort of
like me in vocational school but in this
lab Network what we could then do is in
effect bring the world to them now let's
look at the scaling of all of this so
there's one Earth a thousand cities a
million towns a billion people a
trillion things
there was one Whirlwind computer and my
teammate uh the first real-time computer
there were thousands of pdps there were
millions of hobbyist computers that came
from that billions of personal computers
trillions of Internet of things so now
if we look at this Fab Lab story 1952
was the NC Mill
uh there are now thousands of Fab labs
and the Fab Lab costs exactly the same
cost and complexity of the mini computer
so on the mini computer it it didn't fit
in your pocket it filled a room but
video games email word processing really
anything you do with the internet
anything you do with a computer today
happened at that era because it got on
the scale of a work group not a
corporation
in the same way Fab labs are like the
mini computers inventing how does the
world work if anybody can make anything
then if you look at that scaling
Fab Labs today are transitioning from
buying a machine to make machines making
machines so we're transitioning to you
can go to a Fab Lab not to make a
project to make but to make a new
machine
so we talked about the Deep sense of
self-replication there's a very
practical sense of Fab Lab machines
making Fab Lab machines
and so that's the equivalent of the
hobbyist computer era what it's called
the Altair historically then the work we
spent a while talking about about
assemblers and self-assemblers that's
the equivalent of smartphones and
internet of things that's when so the
the assemblers are like the smartphone
where a smartphone today has the
capacity of what used to be a
supercomputer in your pocket and then
the smart thermostat on your wall has
the power of the original PDP computer
not metaphorically but literally and now
there's trillions of those in the same
sense that when we finally merge
materials with the machines in the
self-assembly that's like the Internet
of Things stage but here's the important
lesson
if you look at the Computing analogy
Computing expanded exponentially but it
really didn't fundamentally change the
the core things happened in in that
transition in the mini computer era so
in the same sense the research now I'm
we spent a while talking about is how we
get to the replicator
today you can do all of that if you
close your eyes and view the whole Fab
Lab as a machine in that room you can
make almost anything but you need a lot
of inputs bit by bit the inputs will go
down and the size of the room will go
down as we go through each of these
stages